une nuit à barmouth
c'est d'abord une bande sonore
les explosions
le roulement des gros calibres
l'artillerie des deux camps déchaîné
sans discontinuer
une seule solution pour échapper à cet
enfer les abris souterrains
ces civils acceptent que nous partagions
leur nuit
six enfants et une vingtaine d'adultes
les jeux vidéo les films pour meubler la
longue soirée qui commence
plus d'électricité des 17 heures
cette fillette vit dans cet abri depuis
six mois avec ses grands-parents sa mère
a dû rester dans une ville prise par les
Russes
on a eu un bombardement juste en face de
chez nous j'ai eu tellement peur et ça
me poursuit toujours quand on est arrivé
ici j'ai vu que c'était pire je me suis
persuadé que je pouvais quand même
survivre j'essaie d'oublier les
bombardements
un autre enfant il a 4 ans
dans le labyrinthe de ce sous-sol humide
ses parents se sont aménagés leur espace
leur vie comme celle de leur fils est en
grand danger mais il refuse d'évacuer
c'est dangereux partout de toute façon
partout en Ukraine il y a cette menace
et au moins ici on est chez nous
un générateur fourni de l'électricité
mais seulement quelques heures pour
économiser le fioul
à l'extérieur au petit matin la bande
sonore est toujours aussi sombre
les soldats Ukrainiens sont encore
embarques certains se battent toujours
d'autres distribuent des vivres
mais beaucoup
reconnaissent qu'ils vont perdre la
ville
il y a une semaine on tenait encore nos
positions mais en ce moment on est
obligé de reculer on va mettre nos
meilleurs soldats plus loin se reprendre
et montrer notre force
malgré cette Persée des Russes pas de
fuite des 5000 civils encore présents
trois centres comme celui-ci sont à leur
disposition dans la journée mais ils
ferment le soir et cette vieille dame
qui doit quitter les lieux comme tous
les autres avant la tombée de la nuit
sur son chemin les explosions
le claquement sec des fusils d'assaut
au début je sursautais tout le temps
mais maintenant je reste calme
la nuit elle s'enferme dans se réduit de
quelques mètres carrés
c'est là que je m'assois
je lis parfois et surtout je récite des
prières
les civils de barmouth sont épuisés et
dans le déni il refuse de croire que
leur ville puisse tomber